NEVER CAUGHT UP IN THEIR LAST
CONTEST AFTER TWO GOALS WERE
SCORED IN CECI AND THAT
DUMP-IN LEA
LINE FOR THE EDMONTON OILERS AND
THE I I
FOR WILLIAM LAGESSON'S FIRST NHL
SLAPSHOT, PELEC OUR CONTESTANT
TONIGHT. TAKING A HIT.
LEON
>> Jay: IN TWO OTHER FINALS IT .
LOOKING TO CENTRE. THE FIRST.
HR
BOUCHARD WITH A SLAPSHOT.
AND THAT DID NOT THE
EDMONTON OILERS NOW IS THAT IS
HOW WE'LL PAY.
IF SOMEOEOSAVING WHAT SEEMED TOA
SLAPPER, DELIVERING A PASS NOW
KILL, BUT SET IT
ALL INTO MOTION, THAT
6'5" FRAME, IN FRONT OF BACK TO.
THROUGH ONE MAN.
NUGENT-HOPKINS, IN WENT TO THE E
AND BENSON THERE, A NICE JOB ON
THAT LINE, LOOKING TO PUSH OUT H
BARZAL OUT TO NELSON, LOOKING
WAITS.
SURVEYS, DISHING NOW.GET THERE,L
FORCE TH
CECI.
PULJUJÄRVI FORECHECK, SIMPLIFIED
THAT LINE TONIGHT AND KANE, OFF
OF THE DRAW, WORKING IT AROUND
FOR BARRIE.
AND NOW I I OILERS, THEY THE PAF
YAMAMOTO, STOOD HIS GROUND
THERE, LET TTHAT TIME A GOOD CHR
PULJUJÄRVI, GETTING APPRECIATIVE
THE TEAMS GETTING AFTER IT A TIE
FOR THE POWER PLAY TO COME
THROUGH.
>> Jack: AND OFF THE DRAW,
WAHLSTROM, OVERSKATES -- AROUND
THE BOARDS,
FLASH THE LEATHER,T
PUCK UP FOR